una cumbre con promesas ambiguas en la
reunión del g20 en roma' los líderes
mundiales se comprometieron a limitar el
calentamiento global en 15 grados para
mediados de siglo de twenty six la cob
26 se construirá sobre una base bastante
sólida ahora se dirige con respecto a lo
que era antes cambiamos el lenguaje with
change de la meta del 1,5 por ciento
ahora está universalmente acordada antes
no grit de before it words pero las
promesas en la cumbre generan inquietud
el secretario general de la onu dijo que
el encuentro había dejado satisfechas
sus expectativas si bien acojo con
satisfacción el nuevo compromiso del g20
con las soluciones globales dejó roma
con mis esperanzas incumplidas pero al
menos no están enterradas los líderes
mundiales llegaron a varios compromisos
pero sin fijar una hoja de ruta clara
entre éstos están lograr la neutralidad
de carbono para mediados de siglo pero
sin determinar una fecha concreta y no
financiarán nuevas centrales de carbón
en extranjero pero sin indicar como
limitarán este tipo de energía en sus
propios territorios además a la cumbre
no acudieron en china ni rusia grandes
emisores de gases de efecto invernadero
algo que el presidente estadounidense
criticó
la excepción es que rusia y también
nosotros rusia sino también china no se
han presentado en términos de
compromisos para abordar el cambio
climático hay una razón por la cual la
gente debería estar decepcionada pero lo
que hemos hecho es que hemos adoptado
una serie de medidas aquí para acabar
con el uso del carbón hemos hecho
compromisos aquí desde todos los lados
todos nosotros en términos de lo que
vamos a aportar en el g20
por su parte el presidente francés
destacó la importancia de la unión entre
los países miembros este g-20 ha sido a
pesar de las tensiones a pesar de las
divergencias que puedan aparecer desde
las negociaciones de los últimos días en
las últimas horas se ha podido confirmar
la convergencia con miras a glasgow pero
a pesar del tono optimista de los
mandatarios lo cierto es que encuentro
concluye sin compromisos claros en un
momento en que la onu urge a que 2050
sea una fecha límite para la neutralidad
de carbono y no sólo una tentativa de
acción